ABC7 has this a warning about porch
pirates in Canada is getting a lot of
attention but not for why you'd think
police in Quebec issued a warning not to
the Pirates themselves but to victims
they were advised that Canadian law
means people should not be posting
videos of alleged package thieves or
risk violating their privacy Canadian
police say instead anyone who has video
evidence of a crime should turn it over
to authorities and not post it publicly
so here is comm's Officer Lieutenant
benois Richard explaining this uh policy
you cannot post the images yourself
because uh you have to remember that in
Canada we have a presumption of
innocence and posting that picture could
be a violation of private life instead
he says if anything is stolen call 911
if you get some proof that somebody
might have stolen something then call
the police give the proof to the police
and then we'll do the the investigation
we will bring that person to Justice and
will file some
charges uh just amazing amazing PE this
epidemic of package thieves people
walking up onto private property and
stealing your private property and the
police and candidate are worried about
uh are worried about the thieves and the
fact that they might be getting publicly
ashamed a presumption of innocence so
I'm just trying to figure this out like
maybe you can help me what what is the
scenario where somebody could walk up on
your porch steal your package off of
your porch and yet be innocent
of
stealing what's the scenario where you
could watch someone steal something from
you and yet they are innocent of
stealing last year because of you
pre-born network of clinics saved over
58,000 babies and thanks to you uh and
to everyone who made this possible we
came down here to Jacksonville with
nothing just the clothes on our back and
I knew I had to change and it was time
to
[Music]
change
so I was just getting on my feet and I
met someone and I got pregnant and I
wasn't ready how am I going to raise a
baby and I barely can take care of my
daughter and myself right now I Googled
abortions and I scheduled an appointment
thinking it was an abortion clinic they
did my first ultrasound seeing the the
ultrasound it impacted me to the point
to where I broke down crying the nurse
reminded me that was a blessing from God
I was thinking about if I wanted to keep
the baby or not when I was at the clinic
after they told me how far long I was
and that the baby had a
heartbeat I cried and it gave me a
minute by myself in the room I broke
down and I prayed to God I asked the
Lord to when I walk out of those doors
to just give me the strength to be able
to go through the pregnancy made my
decision at that time Women's Center
called me out of the blue and said that
they had a lot of stuff for me and they
would like for me to come in they gave
me cribs and diapers and so much stuff
it's amazing touches my heart it makes
me feel special makes me feel like
there's people in the world that does
care they gave me hope the strength to
believe in myself that I could do it
treasure I chose because I know that she
was a gift from God and she's just going
to be a treasure I'm super grateful that
I'm able to go down this journey with my
daughter and I'm just super glad that I
didn't have abortion I've learned how to
trust God how to listen to God and to
trust myself and to do the right thing
and not be selfish it feels
[Music]
amazing when Aunt wette found out that
she was pregnant she was in a bad place
she didn't know how she could uh raise
her child on her own she searched for an
abortion clinic but God led her to a
pre-born clinic where she was introduced
to her baby via ultrasound when she saw
her baby and heard her heart heartbeat
she broke down crying and the nurse
reminded her that a child is a blessing
Antoinette chose life pre-born saves 200
babies each and every day for just $28 a
month you can sponsor an ultrasound and
help save a life when a mother sees her
baby on the ultrasound and hears his
heartbeat she is twice as likely to
choose life so let's join together and
help mothers choose life just dial pound
250 and say the keyword baby that's
pound 250 baby or visit preborn
docomo
docomo package then you can't be sure
the person is guilty um if you saw
somebody taking a package off of
somebody else's door it might look like
they're still but maybe they're not
maybe that's a family member who's going
to collect packages because the resident
is out of town like you know sure but if
it's your package and it's your house
and it's your porch
and someone you don't know takes
it how could they be
innocent okay presumption of
innocence is a legal I think this is
General point that needs to be made here
because we hear this a lot about
innocent till proven guilty okay
innocent till proven guilty is a is a PR
is a legal principle for
courtrooms it doesn't apply to to
individual people it doesn't apply to us
it doesn't apply to like your your brain
okay in your brain you're allowed to see
that someone is doing something and know
that they're guilty and you can even say
it it's only in the courtroom the
courtroom has to pretend essentially or
or or or come in from with with the
premise uh with the starting premise
that that we don't know if you're guilty
or not and we're going to find out in
the course of the court of the
trial okay that in the court outside the
courtroom we don't have to presume
innocence of anybody like you can if you
see someone committing a crime you
obviously know they committed it you
don't have to pretend you don't know
because they haven't been well I just
saw him do this thing but I need to but
now he needs to be a a a jury of people
who didn't see him do it need to also
say that he did it in order for me to
know that he did it no no no that's not
how it
works especially when there's you have a
scenario where they could only be guilty
there's no other explanation well okay
maybe like what would be a scenario
where someone would take your package
and they're not guilty of maybe
if maybe if they thought that the
package was a
bomb and they were running up to take it
to diffuse the
bomb you know and if and and if this is
like a DieHard
scenario uh maybe then that wouldn't C
they're still taking the package though
it doesn't belong to them so technically
I I don't know but maybe in that case
you wouldn't call that is that the
theory I guess it's technically possible
but for all intents and purposes if
somebody takes your package you can be
certain that a theft took place just
like if somebody walks up and punches
you in the face you could be certain
that that an assault has taken place it
happened to you it happened to your face
you were right there right then they
might and you know the thing is they
might end up walking free they a jury
might or a judge might say well yeah
well we don't know if that really
happened everybody else might not but
you know because you saw it if You' like
to see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed